you can just be someone different you
can enjoy whatever you want the
kardashian-jenner family made two
Elwood's Kim Kylie Chloe and Kendall
totally won Halloween
2019 oh I'm gonna tell all of you at
Harvard like I'm gonna be an amazing
lawyer Kim who is an aspiring lawyer
shook the Internet
with her epic recreation of Reese
Witherspoon's character Elle Woods
Harvard admissions seen from Legally
Blonde on Instagram I feel comfortable
using legal jargon in everyday life I
obsessed I'm really freaking out Kim
also had a family-friendly ensemble
adorably dressing her family as the
Flintstones
Kylie rocked not one but six Halloween
costumes this year Madonna a Playboy
bunny Ariel from The Little Mermaid a
sexy fairy Marilyn Monroe and a matching
superhero costume with daughter stormy
while sister Chloe and daughter true
went as a sexy Cruella Deville and an
adorable Dalmatian and mom Kris Jenner
donned a sugar skull mariachi ensemble
Oh Courtney wore two costumes for the
holiday a sultry Vampira while
trick-or-treating with her kids and
later channeled Dolly Parton rocking a
sexy metallic cowgirl getup
Kendyl also got into the Halloween
spirit skipping out on her sister's
family bash for a birthday party and eye
witness tells ET the 23 year old model
kicked off her bday weekend a little
early Kendall who turns 24 on November
3rd celebrated with a private party at
the blind dragon in West Hollywood on
Halloween night looking like a regal
golden fairy and it was a star-studded
affair according to our eyewitness Kacey
Musgraves Kourtney Kardashian Leonardo
DiCaprio Drake Haley Bieber Gigi and
Bella Hadid the weekend Jaden Smith
Lucas ABAT as well as her brother Rob
were also in attendance that's insane
you